la principal reacción que los ciudadanos
estadounidenses han tenido ante el
anuncio de reelección de Joe biden han
sido los temores por la edad que el
demócrata tendrá al finalizar su
hipotético segundo mandato el cual
terminaría con 86 años
estoy un poco molesta es un poco viejo y
si no puede unirme al ejército a los 58
No creo que él deba gobernar el país a
los 80 y cuántos años tendrá 84 es
demasiado viejo definitivamente
demasiado viejo
la postulación de biden provocó que el
expresidente y actual aspirante
republicano Donald Trump de 76 años
criticará duramente su gestión y
catalogar a biden como el peor
mandatario de la historia de Estados
Unidos
una presidencia con tantas calamidades
es casi inconcebible que Joe biden
siquiera considerar hacer candidato a la
reelección ustedes saben lo que pasó en
la anterior elección hicieron trampa y
se robaron las elecciones pero les
prometo esto cuando debatamos y
comparemos nuestros historiales va a ser
la peor pesadilla de los radicales
demócratas porque nunca ha habido un
récord tan malo como esto y nuestro país
nunca ha estado peor
sin embargo las opiniones sobre la
gestión del demócrata son dispares en la
ciudadanía
creo que está haciendo un trabajo
fantástico creo que en este momento
probablemente sea el mejor para vencer a
Trump
creo que es un fracaso y si no estuviera
en el cargo la economía no estaría
arruinada no estaríamos en guerra con
Ucrania quiero decir Ucrania no estaría
en guerra con Rusia
biden mantendrá su actual compañera de
Fórmula kamala Harris de 58 años para su
segundo mandato para los demócratas las
situaciones delicada sin otro nombre de
peso que no sea biden intentarán
retenerlo activo la mayoría en el senado
tras ser minoría en la cámara de
representantes